una ucrania neutral según el modelo
austriaco o sueco la propuesta rusa para
alcanzar un compromiso fue descartada
porque el miércoles según los
negociadores ucranianos el estatus de
neutralidad de austria y suecia es
simplemente inadecuado para un país
atacado por otro
ucrania se encuentra ahora en estado de
guerra directa con rusia por lo tanto el
modelo sólo puede ser ucraniano la idea
propuesta por moscú que ucrania adopte
una política internacional en la línea
de austria y suecia neutral no alineada
con las grandes potencias austria es
neutral desde 1955 un estatus impuesto
por los soviéticos que ocuparon el país
con occidente desde el final de la
segunda guerra mundial desde entonces
viena se ha comprometido a no unirse
nunca a una alianza militar ni a
albergar bases militares extranjeras en
su territorio suecia no se alinea en
tiempos de paz y aspira a la neutralidad
en tiempos de guerra no es miembro de la
alianza atlántica pero sigue siendo un
socio sin embargo como miembros de la
unión europea austria y suecia pueden
contar con la solidaridad de los estados
europeos
ucrania que nos miembro de la unión
europea no quiere renunciar a que
potencias extranjeras garanticen su
seguridad no obstante el presidente
ucraniano ha dicho que renunciaría a
entrar en la otan